[تصفيق]
ترتفع معدلات الاستهلاك كل عام في رمضان
رصدنا هذا اكثر من مره ملايين من المصريين
يتوجهون الى معارض مثل هذا المعرض معرض
اهلا رمضان وهو بالمناسبه منتشر في جميع
انحاء مصر يبحثون عن سلعه مخفضه فهل
بالفعل يجدون ضالتهم في مثل هذه الاماكن
ام يضطرون بسبب موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه
الى تخفيض معدلات الاستهلاك ابراهيم قاسم
يعمل في مصر ولم تسبق له زياره معارض
السلع المخفضه من قبل ولهذا السبب وجدناهم
متابعا جيدا للاسعار في السوق ويعقد
المقارنات اينما صار
انا اول مره اخش النهارده بس جميله اللحمه
ماشي اللحمه دلوقتي المتين متين وحاجه انا
اما اجيب على قد انا ولادي باللحمه برده
هنا ممكن يقول لك دي ب 120 الكفته زي ما
انت علبه التونه ب 20 جنيه هم بره
بيبيعوها ب 30 جنيه ما هو دي حلوه بره مصر
كلها ستصوم خلال الفتره القادمه بمسلميها
في شهر رمضان ومسيحييها الذين يصومون
الصوم الكبير او الاربعيني في نفس الوقت
تقريبا لذلك وجدنا مجدي اسحاق ومجدي وديع
يتسوقان من معرض اهلا رمضان اكيد طبعا
حضرتك كل واحد له ميزانيه والميزانيه بدل
ما اشتري حاجه هشتري عشره منها فطبعا لازم
اقلل من الاستراك واشتري خمسه انا في بيتي
كنت بجيب مكرونه من اللي هي الغاليه مش
هقول طبعا عشان الدعايه وكده النهارده
بجيب نفس المكرونه بس مش سيمولينا بجيبها
دقيق عادي وهو حاجه بتتقضى يعني حاجه بديل
لحاجه يعني الحالم مشابه في الاسواق
الشعبيه حيث يحاول يستهلكون تغيير عاداتهم
الغذائيه من خلال البدائل المتوفره وبعضهم
لا يرى جدوى من الذهاب للمعارض ما لم تكن
قريبه
انا دلوقتي شوف اللحمه بكام دلوقتي نزلت
اهلا رمضان وشفت الاسعار هي الاسعار مخفضه
بس مش قوي يعني بالنسبه لبره هي احسن كل
تاجر بحط سعر بطريقه جنونيه لدرجه ان ممكن
تلاقي السلعه باكثر من ساعه هذا الامر دفع
بشركات المملوكه للدوله واجهات جنسيه للعب
دور في توفير سلع ارخص في محاوله لضبط
الاسواق لو ما نزلتش انا بكميات وبسعر
منافس هتجد ان الاسعار ممكن تعلق لسبب مش
هنوقف حرس على كل بيان السلع ومتوفره في
الاسواق لناحيه الكميات وخاصه بعد حل
مشكلات تتعلق بالاستيراد وتوفير العمله
ولكن تظلوا الاسعار هي الفيصل بالنسبه
للمستهلكين تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره